astra broke valorent
you're right do they funnel through do
they have a leader oh
what
bang
halfway
he's got oh okay the
[Music]
but she was also complicated boring and
made the game pointless to play here's
my head
like
half the time i don't know what i'm
doing dude i just hate astro
you can just have global presence or you
can like solo hold
imagine using
four abilities all at the same time he's
in outer space the whole round while his
team is actually killing people like
he's an astronaut not a valorem player
astra almost ruined ballarat but even
after getting nerfed into the ground she
still represents the future of the game
we get paid thousands and thousands of
dollars
just
press one button pulling them in
i am on a higher plane charlie
literally
hey guys before we get into the video i
wanted to remind you to please subscribe
to the channel and turn on notifications
if you haven't already
it really does help like an astra star
helps you hit a filthy five-man raised
grenade yeah that kind of helped okay so
we all know valorent has been adding
more and more agents to its playable
roster and with every new addition
there's been a bit of a learning curve
people avoided viper at first because
she was a pretty challenging agent to
master she is complicated like you need
to really change the way you play and
people don't want to put that time in
you know jet was and still is basically
the bane of every valor player's
existence jet is a very selfish agent
all of her abilities benefit jet and jet
alone yoru was pretty much a meme
oh what the how did i not see him
basically what i'm trying to say is no
agent is perfect from the get-go but the
celestial time-space bender astra is
kind of a special case
why well because while you could
conceivably draw a parallel between
valor and other agents and weapons and a
character or a mechanic that you've
already seen in another fps
astra is a valorant exclusive
high angle low angle he's trying to
clear all the other potentials and now
he's decided right this has to be at
this where they're gonna be up still
he's gonna try and get that one
that spray couldn't have been better so
what exactly makes astra so different as
the newest of valorance for controllers
astra's main function is impeding the
enemy as opposed to directly dealing
damage but the difference is that
astra's crowd control abilities are
literally out of this world as in she
floats above the map in her astral form
placing stars all over the place
what the
what
she can then use those stars to create
any one of these three things anywhere
on the map a nebula which is essentially
a smoke a nova pulse that concusses
everyone around it when it detonates or
a gravity well that traps players and
pulls them towards its center leaving
those players vulnerable to attacks
looks like you can place them across the
map which in my opinion is pretty op and
i don't think there's any agent that
could do that even the omen smoke has
like a limit to it you're telling me
that i can be like hold on guys i'm
setting up the retake let me just smoke
those let me just uh concuss both sides
of under balcom and let's gravity well
this corner all right guys you ready to
retake
like this just this is this is
ridiculous i think she's broken to an
extent like i don't think it's like
she's not as bad as it was before
because i think when she first came out
it was pretty busted like you pretty
much could like take map control with
like one with like up barrier which is
pretty broken and as if her basic
abilities weren't enough astrazalt
cosmic divide lets her erect a gigantic
nearly soundproof barrier that also
blocks bullets
in theory all of those things sounded
pretty cool but in practice astro was a
map controlling game destroying menace
you know you can set up one of the most
crazy exec by yourselves like you can
literally fake this whole bomb site by
yourself if you wanted to adding like
one teammate with you to make more noise
see astra's abilities gave her control
over the entire map from anywhere she
could hold one site while managing
another she could preemptively set up a
retake before getting to it the
possibilities were endless and the worst
part was that there wasn't really any
counter play you can't interact with
astra she floats above the map placing
her stars and activating them before you
can do anything that combination of
uninteractivity and the repetitive slow
gameplay it takes to both manage and
succeed with astra was terrible for the
game astra can be anywhere on the map
and stop a rush stop anything fast it's
all default out youtube
it's not fun for the viewer the dude's
the igl playing astro everyone else is
doing all the dirty work he's in outer
space the whole round while his team is
actually killing people like he's an
astronaut not a valorem player so astro
was busted boring and almost
uncomfortably overpowered she also
leveled the playing field in some rather
unexpected ways at first but like when
astro first came out that's when i
noticed i was like man it is harder to
play these lower tier teams and thank
god she got the nerf that she did
because she was way more broken before
but even if early on it was possible for
anyone to take advantage of astra's
cracked utils a team needed synergy to
really get the hang of the agent and
utilize her properly and since the pro
scene is where teams have the highest
level of coordination as more time
passed astra saw more and more play in
high level tournaments actually in
capable hands she kind of became the
only controller worth playing and so far
it's like the third round that we see a
five-on-five breed take a gravity well
to a nanoswarm we love to see those
kinds of combos walls about to drop as
they're hearing this one for a while now
and it is on the other side astra damage
oh my god what
he really does he's got the first timing
is good to cross over to the side he'll
be tickled up on the way and i spray as
bars goes down and it's a 1v2 there goes
the cosmic divide they have to push him
down and as they come out of heaven this
could be the ideal scenario for him to
just pick them off on the walk through
there it is one at noon
and a huge clutch to keep crew in it
riot had a pretty huge problem on their
hands with astra not only was she busted
she was breaking the game at all levels
of play she was making pro games
unwatchably boring and casual games
nightmarishly frustrating god i [ __ ]
hate astro
the world would be in peace if
they just removed astra from the video
game
first in patch 3.0 riot increased some
of her cooldowns and made her stars take
longer to activate after a round starts
but that was back in june 2021 astra's
reign of terror lasted for a long time
after that partially because it's hard
to nerf an agent as unique as astra
without either making her useless or
diluting everything that made her so
special in the first place i think the
fake smoke when you pick up a smoke you
could take that away and that would
really harm her kit because that's such
a huge part of astra
uh
one of the other ones but i think it
would be overkill is
once you place a star down you can't
pick it up and that would make people
need to be a lot more cognizant of where
they're putting it or whatever but
beyond those two i don't know what you
can do to really
not just
make her a yoru and the scope of the
problem went beyond just astra herself
her balance issues revealed some of the
problems with the other agents in the
game like brimstone's limited smokes for
example i think right now the bigger
problem is that
the other agents like omen and brimstone
aren't viable at all compared to her kit
so it's kind of just like
i guess she's just
not overpowered but at least the other
agents kind of just fall short
bro
bro after months of unchecked astra
dominance patch 4.04 finally cut her
down to size and tried to bring her in
line with other controllers riot even
admitted that they created a monster
writing quote with the mastery of
astra's play patterns over time she's
become an overwhelming force in both
coordinated and high mmr play she's
crowded out brimstone and omen by
replicating their strengths and they
simply couldn't keep up with the
map-wide impact of her utility so they
nerfed everything she has fewer stars
longer cooldowns on retrieving them
longer cooldowns on all her basic
abilities and the gravity well is
smaller now in theory this should all
make her a less overwhelming opponent
now with this new meta uh definitely
more possibility and something more
viable and they can definitely compete
now with the whole astra viper meta
let's say you're trying to help your
team get map control and you take back a
star that's like 45 seconds you have to
wait so
to help a team it's like more of a risk
for astra now so you kind of have to use
your util for yourself more
now
it's truly anyone's game the astra meta
is over and other characters can finally
get some play time again we need to go
go yeah yeah yeah
stimming go go go go go go go go go
even though the astra meta is finally
over there's a lot we can learn from
this whole mess valrant is still a very
new game and characters like astra are
entirely unprecedented
when you're reinventing the fps with a
character who plays an rts while
shooting sometimes you have to shoot
your shot and hope for the best even if
that means releasing a broken agent
oh my god we put them in the meat
grinder and grinded them up because no
matter how broken she was as a unique
valorant offering astro was a move in
the right direction if riot's shooter
planned to ever carve out its own fps
identity news for now there's that
utility invested gonna pull him away
from the defuse by a little bit more
time and close the gap and another
investment coming out from chao this is
beautiful i'll play that time as best he
can
now chronicle surely shall's gonna check
this that's gonna get to halfway you've
got to try and make this happen for
yourself
and chronicle it's down to the wire but
i think he's oh i thought he had gone
down on that that was so close but just
timed well enough i don't think astra is
dead i think that the way your user has
to be different so before you can
control the entire map you can put stars
take them back and then
do all that but now you kind of have to
use it more
selfishly so
she's more of like a sentinel now where
you you have to like anchor site with
her i think she'll still be played on
some maps i think there's like two or
three maps that she's still viable on
but then like the other maps omen abram
is just more
more viable at the end of the day even
though the nerf ultimately made a lot of
people happy astr was an insane agent
with an incredibly cool design and she
still does represent the future of
valorant hopefully that future just
isn't so busted next time vanity now in
a 1v4 he's in the only spot that could
possibly succeed be successful for this
player gravity while going in
he got the kill he got the
kill or you can't eat onions i might
give up cheese i might be like i'll just
eat vegan cheese yeah serious because
vegan vegan cheese is not that bad but
there's no replacement for onions if you
want onions there's nothing else that
subs in as an onion onions are they're
one of a kind you can't you can't
replace them